in an advance that could help shed light
on the causes of skin disorders
researchers at the Rockefeller
University in New York have developed a
new technique to study skin development
in living mice it allows you to look at
complex genetic pathways in a way that
was inconceivable using conventional
Mouse genetics most researchers who
study skin biology and animal models
tend to rely on transgenic mice but
creating these genetically engineered
animals is a slow and laborious process
that involves crossbreeding mice for
several generations and these
experiments often take years to get
right so here we wanted to develop a new
technology a technology that would allow
us to much more quickly work our way
through the functional importance of of
gene expression changes in gene
expression in the skin Elaine Fuchs and
her team turned to a relatively new tool
called RNA interference they identified
around 150 genes that were either over
or under expressed in skin and then
designed short sequences of RNA that
could silence the key genes in the
developing mice to make the technique
work they injected viruses encoding the
interfering RNA into embryos at just the
right developmental stage for early skin
development around nine and a half days
old with this approach the researchers
can silence just about any gene they
want in the animal's skin I think what
we haven't done is that we have shown
for the first time that you can go and
you can knock down a gene in vivo in
skin and see what its outcome is the
technique should now allow researchers
to more robustly dissect the complex
genetic and molecular interactions that
play out just below the surface of the
body skin it's an extremely powerful
tool because it allows us to be able to
look at developmental consequences at
any stage along the line we're in a
position where we can now simply
wait for the developmental process to
occur and then take a look at what are
the functional consequences this
approach should help scientists better
understand a number of skin conditions
ranging from eczema to acne to skin
cancer so far Fuchs team has
demonstrated the power of the technique
by wiping out a number of genes involved
in skin cancer importantly the
researchers found that the technique was
completely safe for the animals the
approach doesn't seem to be harmful to
the mothers or the embryos the the
mothers seemed to recover very well and
are able to get pregnant and give birth
again afterwards and the embryos are
usually perfectly fine we've never seen
them be injured by the by the injection
itself so for any researchers who have
shied away from using mice because of
their complex genetics perhaps it's time
to give the rodents a second chance if
you enjoy working on worms and you enjoy
working on flies because the ease of
doing genetics you'll enjoy applying
this technology to work on mice for
Nature Medicine I'm a lead organ
you